a few months ago my teenager son told me
he said I had an exhausting dream and I
said what happened and he said I joined
that I was a negative number and I
couldn't figure out my square root and
to comfort him and also to alleviate
this extension crisis I said well there
is a way wait until you know the
imaginary number and in even long I'm
not stupid
I know imaginary numbers he said but I
just don't like that troublesome I and I
thought you know that troublesome I so
was blaming him so during 16th and 17th
century when imaginary numbers were
first introduced some of the
mathematicians looked down upon
imaginary numbers as fiction fictitious
or useless so here's a cartoon I
borrowed from my younger son math room
it says I felt get real and the
imaginary number the number says be
rational I feel like I'm sorry I just
have to add I feel like she'll spice or
not you know every other style is pretty
rational versus real this is of course
there's a lot to say about those pair we
can go through philosophy we can go to
psychology neuroscience and many other
branches to study this concentration the
conflicts and the affinity between the
two coming from a writer's point of view
I want to share a few stories a few
years ago I was hospitalized twice for
suicide attempt and here are few stories
I brought from the hospital the first
woman I saw when I entered a ward
I'll give her name Lena she was in her
late 20s
and she had a fighting career in fashion
industry my first impression of her was
that she moved very slowly every gesture
every step why I didn't know and in a
place where people are oftentimes
cloaked in paper gowns carelessly she
dressed as impeccably as she could but
we know of the quietest most unselfish
fuming and most elegant person there
during the following weeks we befriended
each other and she told me a little
about her childhood she was born in a
family of five siblings father was in a
Serbian army her mother was an albanian
orphan from Kosovo and was set to walk
around Becky
until she met Lane as father and married
him after the Kosovo war
Lena's mother disappeared where did she
go I asked her and she said they thought
her mother without having them returned
to Kabul did your father think of
looking for her I asked and later said
no why did lanús mother leave I didn't
ask her it's one of those big wife will
never find an answer to
instead we talk about other things as an
aspiring designer Lina would give me
fashion advice and prescribed to me all
the outfits I should get when I leave
the hospital and how to wear them at a
time I thought why do I want to think
about how to roll my sleeves up
elegantly when I can see little point in
living
I never asked me now why she was in the
hospital I don't think that's a question
anyone asked of anyone unless
information is volunteered the one day
shortly before she left she said to me
do you think there's anything wrong with
me
what's wrong with me is I have a broken
heart that is not another
to put me in a hospital and on those
medications a broken heart with him as
Lena why is your heart broken we can't
ask her why do other people with broken
hearts don't end up here when broken
hearts are everything phenomena because
that is to say there's something a
matter with how your heart is broken
perhaps it's down wrongly it's a bill to
say they're rational reactions when a
heart is broken and your reaction are
not rational
in fact her whole existence reminds me
of one of my most favorite characters of
all time Charlie Brown Charlie Brown
have had most wife and I like this one
Crescent even though it's not a white
person it is a white person how can we
lose when we are so sincere after
Porsha's question how can how can people
not love me when I'm so seen here and
when I love them
in the second story I'll call this young
woman leave she was deeply depressed and
sometimes she would stay for hours in
bed without moving and this is a place
you know where all the doors were open
to everybody so you could see these
things and the only time she came out of
her room was to be on the phone and
those were the payphones the old-style
payphones with metal button you could
punch and when she was on the phone he
could see her come alive in a most
desperate way my understanding of a
story came from hearing her talk on the
phone and there was a domestic partner
out there in the world who had
threatened to cut her head off if he
ever see her again
she did not want to leave the hospital
the doctors wanted to relieve her she
said no now she said she was depressed
but she was not delusional
in the adapter from a different world
had to come and assess her the question
of course was was she telling the truth
was she only imagining the unreal now
one day she said on the phone to someone
listening on the other side she said I
don't care
send me to a state hospital locked me up
in prison do anything can't you see I
don't want to go out to the world
because I don't want to die that's only
the most compelling plea to me but the
confrontation between the real and the
rational is murky in life even more so
in a psychiatric hospital sometimes is
the irrational that is the real
sometimes is the unreal that leads to
the most rational response
[Music]